I have a question for you uh when you
get elected here are you going to move
would you vote to impeach Joe Biden I
don't I don't think impeachment is good
especially because we'd get Kamala uh
running the show and that would that
would be bad yeah but I mean I guess my
issue with that is do you just let
someone get away with
illicit activities because someone else
might be worse or do you just say we
have to uphold the law regardless of the
outcome I kind of like the latter more I
I don't I mean after we saw Democrats
basically waste two years of the Trump
presidency trying to impeach him twice
uh I'm not really convinced it's that
effective a
thing to do I'd much rather expose
corruption and sort of see where that
goes but yeah I think after seeing how
destructive impeachment is I mean
there's no doubt the Biden
Administration is Lawless and has been
promoting Lawless activity since he was
a presidential candidate I don't know
how effective a use of our time that is
so
before he becomes president or in the
previous administration in the previous
previous administration
Hunter Biden is on the board of an
energy company
he's getting 83 000 a month that's been
reported Victor Shook and the prosecutor
was investigating mycolas lachevski the
founder of barisma I believe there are
around a dozen or so open active
investigations some were like
temporarily suspended or on hold but
they existed Matthew JB reported that so
fact check me on that one because I I
mean if the number's wrong
Joe Biden comes in after an email was
sent between one of these consulting
firms and then he uh tells the the the
the president to fire the prosecutor
otherwise he's going to withhold a
billion dollars in aid from the US
government which he doesn't have the
authority to do
so Joe Biden is doing what is very
obvious
and uh most people believe should be
investigated Donald Trump said take a
look into this and what happened they
impeached him for
now as President Joe Biden every over
the past three months has been asking
for tens of billions of dollars to be
given to Ukraine
this is in my opinion evidence of
malfeasance
sure enough I mean I get it Ukraine's at
War
but how fascinating that the guy who's
asking for favors who's got his kid
running these businesses with barisma is
now all of a sudden using taxpayer funds
for a non-ally non-nato non-eu nation in
their conflict
this dude is in my opinion committing
very very serious and obvious crimes
should he at least be investigated which
dude I mean
the investor I mean yes I mean we
obviously have to look into into any
possible
yeah corruption yeah
um I think he's I I think I my opinion
yeah is that he's stealing money from
the taxpayer to pay off his buddies and
that's what he's been doing since the
beginning of this whole operation
I think that um I mean we need to
actually investigate any corruption
whether it is in the Biden family I mean
some of the reporting I did was also on
other people you've never heard of like
Joe Kiani who is Biden has said in one
of his speeches in 2015 this is one of
my closest friends he gave he has given
millions of dollars to Biden Ventures
whether it was the Biden Institute at
Penn whether it was the Biden Super PAC
the Biden presidential campaign oh lo
and behold his company is getting
millions of dollars of federal contracts
from the Biden Administration and he's
on a prestigious Biden board for science
and technology advisors so I think that
a lot of the corruption that I've
reported and that my colleagues at the
Free Beacon have reported on would again
be national news like Joe Kiani would be
a national figure like Scott Pruitt was
during the Trump Administration he'd be
a national figure if all he did was
shine Trump's shoes and then do
something else exactly so look I think
that actual oversight is incredibly
important to do whether the president is
a Republican or the president is a
Democrat and Democrats we know will not
do any of this because so I've also
reported they literally don't show up
for work let alone actually going after
their political allies in this
Administration so I think there the sky
is the limit when it comes to corruption
in the administration I'm 25 but I can
tell you with confidence this is the
most corrupt administration of my
lifetime and I think it's important for
us to show the American people of that
so anyway to your question that is an
issue is forcing good government but
then also stopping The Reckless spending
that's destroying our economy via
inflation that the administration denies
crushing communist China stopping giving
Iran nuclear weapons actually promoting
American jobs and American Energy the
department of energy of course doesn't
actually believe in energy it's
incredibly hostile to American Energy
and American Energy creators so the
first step is to stop a lot of the
madness that we're seeing from Democrats
and the Biden Administration and then we
can start laying out sort of a vision of
hey here's why you guys should give us
the white house but the first thing I
think is staunch the bleeding and then
proceed accordingly have you heard of
graphene
graphene have you heard of graphene uh
no it's a carbon morphine he's like a
gradient maybe a new structure of
material that's one atom thick this is
it actually right here it's a wonder
material it's going to be the steel of
the 21st century and then we can get the
United States on board with creating
this stuff and mass will become a global
superpower what do you think with 2024
Trump or DeSantis I I like it all the
above Energy Solution I haven't heard of
that though
um Materials Science it's the way to go
that's how you win elections I like it
um I think 2024 is light years away so
let's like right now the most important
election for me is July 19th in this
primary then November 8th
um DeSantis has to win this year right I
mean it's going to be a red wave but
just keep in mind having this
conversation in 2014 we were probably
talking about people who were going to
go on to lose that year so obviously
DeSantis will destroy whoever they
nominate but something crazy could
happen with him something crazy could
happen with Trump so first let's have
the Red Wave like we can't take
advantage like we can't forget that we
have an election this year by getting
distracted by the shiny object of 2024
yet we got to win this year how much of
it is like what idealists like what you
want versus the the the political game
the football game of who's there how can
I get this many people to do that that's
a really good question I have no idea
um
I'll come on as a member of Congress and
I'll get back to you I literally don't
know you know it's sort of circle back
Mr Smith well no but honestly I'm not
gonna lie and say oh I can tell you what
it's going to be like to be a
congressman as a 25 year old I am
incredibly idealistic and maybe that
means I'm somewhat naive but I think
that having people go who want to get in
there on day one and start investigating
corruption and making a difference you
know what matters who we elect right
that's why I jumped in this primary is I
was like look I'm 25 but I have no doubt
done more to expose Democrats corruption
and malfeasance than anyone else in this
race and that's why we have to actually
send someone to watch and who wants to
do that I I think the the problem for uh
the problem that many of us see the
Democrats corruption is fairly obvious I
mean look Jimmy Dore who's a leftist
yeah and he Rags on the Democrats all
day and night even Hassan
he Rags on the Democrats all the time I
think we all can see the problem with
with Democrats the problem I have with
Republicans is that they're a barrier
preventing actual America like
pro-america pro-american worker
politicians from getting in you see
what's happening with Robbie Starbuck uh
yeah absolutely the machine of the
Republican party just wants to be a
machine a fat gluttonous power absorbing
machine that does nothing to help
anybody and we heard this from I think
it was Thomas Massey Marjorie Taylor
green the freedom caucus basically that
actually no no who was who was the other
guy we had from the freedom caucus
I don't remember his name was the name
was it Randy or something yes it was
Randy Weber Randy Weber yeah I think it
was him he was saying that he could have
been the vote to over to to repeal uh
Obamacare but they were like no no no no
no don't do that don't because we need
the issue we need to pretend we're
fighting against something that's the
problem I see with Republicans I think
Democrats are the same way but so long
as we have the standard Republican
leadership nothing's going to change
well that's why I think it's important
that we actually not only flip the house
but it depends who we're sending there
and so you know when I'm talking to
people when I'm going knocking in there
to say oh you're 25 that's really
exciting but you know what can you
actually do
and I say look yeah you're right I I'm
25 but I think sort of our generation of
people does not is not as beholden to
sort of that type of Politics as we've
been used to for I think all of our
Lives whether it's because we're not way
too idealistic we're already way too
cynical in blackfield
um you know I think a lot of the same
old Samuel doesn't really fly with us
here's what I think is going to happen
yeah I think if
you do get in yeah and you do not go
after Joe Biden with impeachment
investigations and an attempt attempted
conviction then
it's going to be the Republicans being
like we don't want to destroy everything
we don't want to waste time and then the
Democrats will keep doing it yeah then
the leftists will claim the Republicans
are the scorched Earth party while the
Republicans are the Washington generals
and then I see people like Kyle Kolinski
claim the Democrats are actually the
Washington generals and I'm just like
you know
in 2016 uh you know after after the
midterms
when the Republicans had basically
everything they went along with
russiagate
When Donald Trump sees obvious issues
with Ukraine he gets impeached and the
Republicans do nothing when it comes to
the 2020 election across all of these
states Republicans cut deals with
Democrats to change voting laws
if the Republicans are unwilling to play
politics in the same way then it will be
the same thing Democrats will keep
steamrolling they will keep we will keep
seeing changes that are negative it is
just a slow roll and in 20 years
Republicans will be transgender
Communists sacrifice all their values
because they'll keep lurching leftward
however I believe if the Republicans do
decide we're going to impeach Joe Biden
we're going to go for a conviction we're
going to investigate we're going to
arrest the Democrats won't just sit back
and allow it to happen it's going to be
the same policies which is just a powder
keg and then and then you get some kind
of chaos collapse or otherwise so I
don't know what the answers are I just
know that for me sitting back watching
Democrat corruption
sitting back and seeing the media lie
and work in collusion with the
Democratic establishment seeing big Tech
do all of these things and then seeing
the established Republicans who are all
in on the game sitting on their hands
the whole time I'm just like we need
people like Lauren bobert or Marjorie
Taylor green or Thomas Massey more
freedom caucus individuals who are just
going to be like we're gonna we're gonna
push back we're gonna say no we need
term limits too and especially for the
administrative State as well like that
that Trump's military were relying to
him about the troops in Syria about the
numbers of troops we had in Syria that's
an administrative problem those guys
should have been term limited out I mean
the president obviously can hire whoever
wants but I think we should have some
legal restrictions there maybe the
president shouldn't be able to hire
whoever he wants or she wants
um but a lot of those people you're
talking about are not hired by the
president a lot of those people are
these career you know that sort of is
where the Deep state is from is these
career people who are actually
explicitly not hired by the President
right those are the careers the people
hired by the president are the
politicals that's where you have when
you're a Democrat you have two forces
aligned in your favor you have the
career employees and the political
appointees when you're a republican
especially when you're Trump you have
the careers aligned against you and then
you have your political appointees so
you're still fighting your own
government employees who are also
impossible to fire when they're doing a
bad job but being able to reform the
career hires in the government would be
a huge win for taxpayers for the
government transparency for anything
like that how do you get anything done I
you know it's like there's like 10
members of Congress who are actually
like hey maybe we should change this and
everyone else is like don't rock the
boat we get to eat steak houses the
government pays for it I want to go home
that I mean it's a it is a problem with
both sides obviously of just sort of the
lackadaisical attitude as we have these
massive problems but again that's why
it's important for any voter in any
District in the country to go sort of
ask the people who are asking for their
vote hey what do you plan on actually
doing when you're in there and that's
why I can say in good conscience to
voters yes I understand I'm 25. but look
at what my reporting has already done
when it's something like education for
example I got the governor of Tennessee
to quash planned social justice grants
at State schools in Tennessee a
professor reached out to me he said hey
I teach at the University of Memphis
which is a Public School in Tennessee
and our school is bribing professors to
incorporate the University of memphis's
social justice principles why does the
school even have those things in
Tennessee I don't know uh and I said
I've never seen that in the years that I
have been a higher ed and K-12 education
activists so I wrote the article
exposing that this program exists I
contact the Governor of Tennessee's
office I said hey what is going on here
and then the next week that program is
canceled so being able like you can use
governmental powers for good to stop
leftist insanity but you need people in
government who are actually going to
either expose it themselves or when
contacted with these sorts of tips
actually do things about it thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there